-Night, welcome back.
Thank you for being here.
I appreciate this.
-Man, thank you for having me.
-I was so happy to meet
your beautiful wife backstage.
You were telling me
you guys went on a vacation.
And I don't see you as kind of
fanboying out or freaking out,
but you met someone and you kind
of freaked out a little bit.
-Yeah, I mean,
generally speaking, you know,
kind of -- You know, I've met
so many wonderful people,
some of them
celebrities and famous people.
And kind of, you know, for me,
the thing that's
most important
is kind of your --
the thing that your sacred --
that you consider sacred,
the thing you're
connecting to as an artist,
that you keep that precious,
that that's the thing
that you protect as a musician
or an artist or a painter
or whatever it is.
And so that's how I judge,
you know, for myself
how much I'm authentic.
And so not often do I
see someone
that I'm, like --
I'm, like, speechless.
And then we were on vacation,
and I got up from the table
and went down the hall.
And Paul McCartney
bumped into me in the hallway.
And I'm like, "Hi, sir.
I'm a..."
I'm never like this.
And I'm like, "Hi, sir.
I'm -- You know,
I'm M. Night Shyamalan.
I'm a filmmaker. I'm a big fan."
And he's like, "Oh, wow!
You tell stories. You're great."
And then he was so gracious
and he was so beautiful.
And we sat there in the hall
and we talked forever
in this hallway.
And he was asking me everything
about filmmaking
and why and how and what --
you know, how do I tell stories?
And then his grandkids
kept coming up,
and they were like, you know,
"Grandpa, where are you?"
You know?
And he was like, "You know, this
is a very important filmmaker."
He was introducing me
to his grandkids.
-Wow!
-It was so beautiful.
-Do you get that excited,
in general, in life?
I mean, you're always
very chill when I meet you.
Are you writing another script
or something like that?
-I am. This morning -- I am.
I'm writing a new script.
I wouldn't come here
until I got my four pages done.
And I --
-Is that right?
-Yeah.
And I got my four pages done.
I was stuck around three pages
and I was like, "Uh-oh.
I'm not going to make the show."
-You're gonna cancel on me?
-Dude, I won't do it.
I won't come. I won't come.
-"I'm not coming on
'Fallon' tonight."
But you have
the number-1 movie right now.
You knocked out "Avatar."
-Aw, thanks, man.
-I mean, come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-You've got to celebrate.
-I -- thank you.
-"Knock at the Cabin" --
You don't celebrate.
-You know, look, I'll celebrate
the Eagles on Sunday.
-Alright, yeah, yeah, yeah.
This is a very young Night right
here with your dad and a camera.
That's a good photo.
-That sofa used to have
plastic on it.
You know how the parents
used to keep plastic --
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, of course.
-So that must have been
a real special occasion.
they took the plastic off.
-Yeah. Just for the photo.
-Yeah, for the photo.
-Then, after the photo,
put the plastic back on.
-My dad is at home.
I'm gonna have him watch this.
And, you know, I think, you
know, now he's very, very old.
He had some strokes.
And, you know, he used to be
so excited about
me being famous and successful,
and now it's just his kid
when I come over.
Like, I think he forgets
all of this.
-Is that right?
-Kind of beautiful.
-Aww. And he's just like,
"Yeah, my son's here."
-"Yeah, my son's here," yeah.
-And how are your kids?
-They're amazing.
My daughters
are older and artists.
And one of them is in Ireland.
She's a filmmaker.
She's gonna start her --
do her first film.
-What?!
-Yeah. Amazing.
And the oldest one
is an incredible musician.
And they're touring.
And, just, you know,
amazing, yeah.
-This is cool. Good. I'm happy.
You -- We were --
-Thank you, guys.
-We were talking backstage.
You said you were playing
Cards Against Humanity.
-Yeah.
-Which I love.
We know that game
is a great game.
And this card came up.
You said this is
one of the honors in your life?
-Well...
[ Laughter ]
-This is one of
the biggest things
that happened in your life?
Not the number-1 movie.
Don't care.
But if you're a card in
Cards Against Humanity,
you've finally made it?
-You know, whenever these kind
of pop-culture things happen,
it's very odd.
Like, my mom will
call and be like,
"You're on 'Wheel of Fortune.'"
And I'm like, "Great, Mom."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, I love you, Mom.
That's awesome.
-She gets real excited.
We were at my in-laws' house,
and she --
My sister-in-law picked -- We're
playing Cards Against Humanity.
We've all been drinking.
And then she picks a card
and she starts screaming.
-Yeah.
-"Oh, my God!"
And I'm like, "Okay, alright."
She said, "It's you, it's you!"
And then so I was like,
"Let's play the game.
Let's keep playing the game."
I'm very competitive.
And so I was like,
"Let's play the game."
And then we play.
And I give a very funny answer,
like, empirically
the funniest answer.
It's just the funniest answer.
-Of course.
-And she did not pick me.
She picked her husband.
-Yeah, you can't --
-I didn't even win that round.
-You can't let it all
go to your head.
Yeah, exactly.
-Yeah.
-Everyone's got to
keep you humble. Come on.
Let's talk about
"Knock at the Cabin."
-Yeah.
-It opened Friday, number 1
at the box office this weekend.
You recently said
this might be your best film.
Can you set up what it's about?
-Well, "Knock"
is based on a book,
and it's a about a family
that goes on vacation
into a cabin in the woods.
And four strangers
come with weapons.
They're very menacing.
And they break in.
And they tell this family
that they've had
visions of the end of the world.
And the world
is gonna come to an end,
and the only way to stop it
is if one of
these three family members
chooses to kill
one of the other family members.
And if not,
the world comes to an end.
-How do you think of
these crazy ideas?
I mean, but you're such
a nice guy, a friendly guy.
I mean, look at this kid.
He's hanging out.
He's playing with cameras.
And then he's doing this.
Like, you've gotta kill one
of your family members?
I mean, oh, my gosh.
-Well, you know, I --
-You just like storytelling.
-Well, I do.
This one came from a book
that was submitted to me.
But the next three movies, like,
I know the next three movies
in my head.
And it's very --
It's a very precious thing.
I don't really --
You know, I'm very scared
that I'm going to stop
coming up with ideas.
And, you know, I was watching
"Signs" the other day,
which we had a 20th anniversary.
And for a charity thing we did,
we screened "Signs,"
which is 20 years old.
-Is it 20 years old?
-20 years old.
And I was watching myself
on-screen,
but also remembering
when I wrote it
and the ideas I came up with.
And I was just -- how you're not
guaranteed that,
for 20 years, you're going to
come up with ideas,
and so I just kind of hoard
the ideas.
I'm scared, you know,
that I'm gonna one day wake up
and not be inspired.
-You will never, ever
run out of ideas.
You're M. Night Shyamalan.
Come on, buddy.
You're the best.
You can't run out of ideas.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Ever.
It's never going to happen.
-Thanks.
-I want to show everyone a clip
from "Knock at the Cabin."
Take a look at this.
-Do you really think that
everything
that happened today...
everything we've seen...
do you really think
it's all just a coincidence?
-Yes. I think it's all
a coincidence,
some horrible,
unexplainable coincidence.
Or it has to be a trick.
I have to believe that.
-You already don't believe that.
-Ooh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
M. Night Shyamalan.
"Knock at the Cabin"
is in theaters now.
We'll be right back with
stand-up from Orlando Leyba.
Stick around, everybody.